[Musica]
[Applauso]
per quanto tu cammini e per quante
strade tu possa percorrere
non troverai mai i confini dell'anima
così profonda e la sua vera essenza
queste parole ci riportano molto
indietro nel tempo
si tratta infatti del frammento di un
opera di un filosofo greco eraclito
vissuto nel sesto secolo avanti cristo
ma lo stesso eraclito dobbiamo anche
un'altra fulminante sentenza quella che
dice
il sole non
oltrepasserà i confini
altrimenti le furie che sono ministre
della giustizia lo afferravano e lo
riporteranno dentro i confini
eraclito era
soprannominato dai suoi
contemporanei l'oscuro
perché si riteneva che parlasse in
maniera incomprensibile
ma se riflettiamo insieme in margine ai
due frammenti che ho letto
possiamo certamente stabilire che ciò
che eraclito intende dire tutt'altro che
oscuro anzi è di cristallina chiarezza
che cosa vogliono dire i due frammenti
che ho letto
ma essenzialmente
sottolineano due aspetti importanti
relativi al concetto di confine
anzitutto che i confini ci sono
esistono i confini anche
indipendentemente dal fatto che
riusciamo effettivamente a raggiungerli
può accadere che non riusciamo a
trovarli
e tuttavia i confini ci sono e dovremo
tentare di uniformare il nostro
comportamento
alla consapevolezza dell'esistenza di
consigli
e poi i due frammenti di eraclito ci
dicono un'altra cosa importante
ci dicono che non si devono superare i
confini
perché
oltrepassare il confine
è fare
ingiustizia e macchiarsi di una colpa
che presto o tardi sarà sanzionata
tenete presente che in tutto il mondo
greco
arcaico e classico la colpa fondamentale
si chiamava libris e la hybrid è proprio
il tentativo di andare al di là dei
confini che sono fissati
insomma spero che sarete d'accordo nel
ritenere che eraclito non era affatto un
filosofo
oscuro né che dicesse delle cose
incomprensibili
anzi ci ha aiutato a impostare la nostra
riflessione
sul concetto di confine
ma si tratta anche di andare oltre
le sentenze di un filosofo antico per
andare davvero a fondo del concetto di
confine
e allora oltre a tutte le cose che sono
state già dette in maniera ammirevole
dagli altri speaker io vorrei attirare
la vostra attenzione
soprattutto su due
caratteristiche peculiari della nozione
di confine
caratteristiche che non sempre vengono
individuate e riconosciute come tali
la prima
il confine è capace di convertire
la quantità e qualità
provate a pensarci il tracciare il solco
il
formulare il confine
attiva istituisce alcune polarità che
sono fondamentali dal punto di vista
qualitativo
la polarità interno esterno dentro fuori
familiare estraneo dritto storto giusto
erroneo
da questo punto di vista
noi potremmo dire che il confine
conferma quello che un grande pensatore
del novecento uno dei massimi dei
giganti del pensiero filosofico
contemporaneo
aveva osservato a proposito della
qualità degli spazi
l'autore a cui mi riferisco e michelle
fuco il quale parte da una constatazione
elementare con la quale possiamo
certamente
convenire e cioè
abitualmente si pensa che le differenze
che intervengono nello spazio possono
essere solo
differenze quantitative
una porzione di spazio più grande o più
piccola più lunga più larga
e cioè noi siamo pronti a riconoscere
elementi geometrici
descrittivi dello spazio ma quello che
non sempre
riconosciamo è che lo spazio gli spazi
hanno una loro specifica qualità
che talora è difficile da riconoscere
è la qualità che ad esempio vediamo
funzionare quando ci riferiamo ad una
esemplificazione
limpida trasparente e cioè l'origine del
tempio voi sapete che il tempio come
luogo di accoglienza del divino ha una
storia antichissima e bene prima ancora
che i templi fossero
costruzioni era sufficiente tracciare un
solco con una forma circolare o una
forma rettangolare
per trasformare la qualità dello spazio
circoscritto dal solco quello spazio
diventava lo spazio del sacro lo spazio
qualitativamente diverso dal resto dello
spazio
anche se apparentemente non si
registrava alcuna differenza
ma vi è e con questa meraviglia a
concludere una seconda peculiarità della
nozione di confine che mi permetto di
raccomandare alla vostra attenzione
è stato detto anche da questo palco
questa sera
che il confine è la linea che separa
che istituisce uno scarto che include ed
esclude ma ciò che è davvero più
caratteristico del confine el kun
è il fatto che quel sinis quella linea
che
circoscrive e traccia il solco è un
luogo di incontro
è un luogo di rapporto
nello spazio
qualitativo del confine di quel confine
che è cool io in contro l'altro ed è lì
che allora va in gioco la mia identità
che posso cercare di definire
solo in rapporto
all'alterità dell'altro come definire la
mia identità seno nel rapporto con
l'altro da questo punto di vista il
confine è appunto luogo di un incontro
nel quale
conquistò la mia identità
nel rapporto con l'altro si nel rapporto
con l'altro ma a
condizione che o
quell'altro sia disposto a riconoscerlo
nella sua
radicale alterità rispetto a me che non
lo polsi ieri tale da poter essere
accettato solo se mi assomiglia perché
allora perderebbe la sua alterità e
farebbe smarrire a me
l'identità che nasce dal rapporto con
l'altro e sul confine
concetto in cui è fondamentale come
dicevo il kun e che lo differenzia da
altri concetti apparentemente
simili come ad esempio
frontiera mentre nella frontiera
io mi trovo in una condizione nella
quale
affronto l'altro è presto tardi questo
affrontarsi questo
confrontarsi è probabile che degeneri a
scontro nel confine prevale il kun e nel
confine incontro lo straniero
quella radicalmente altro da me che mi
fa dono della mia identità
e che io devo accogliere anche se non so
non posso sapere all'incontro con
l'altro se hospes e cioè ospite amico o
se hostis e cioè nemico non posso
saperlo ma devo ugualmente accoglierlo e
non per generosità
ma perché devo costruire la mia identità
solo nel rapporto con l'altro
insomma come vedete
come vedete
questi concetti ci fanno ritornare alla
mente la sentenza di eraclito
per quanto tu cammini
e per quante strade tu possa percorrere
non troverai mai i confini dell'anima
così profonda è la sua vera essenza
grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]